dramatic new images from Gray's Anatomy
star Katarina scorsone's devastating
house fire
La is home for me right now we spoke
with Katarina hours before she posted
the heartbreaking loss in January her
home burned down she had only two
minutes to get her three kids out of the
house and escaped with barely the shoes
on their feet sadly all four family pets
died but just like her character on
Grace Katarina has emerged stronger and
grateful to family and castmates who
sent clothing and supplies then came
this big announcement you guys are
renewed for season 20. show me the face
you made when you found out I don't
think I was that surprised
show me the face that you made when you
heard you are coming back for season 20.
actually was this
I just think we were like ah it's
amazing yep Gray's is now officially the
longest running medical drama in prime
time but there are big changes Ellen
Pompeo has stepped back and her TV
sister Kelly McCreary is leaving ABC's
Thursday night show when do we stop
doing each other the benefit of the
doubt is the door open to come back
um I certainly hope so yeah you would
you're down
foreign
[Music]